hi thanks so much for being here one of
the women Johan allegedly pursued while
married to Danielle joins the tell all
her name is memory and it's so ironic
because Johan claims he doesn't remember
her you can't make this stuff up I
believe that he doesn't remember her I
think he has so many well memory details
her relationship with Johan and brings
the receipts do you have the
conversation I got all of it right here
plus sarper is making himself and
shakina look even worse as he explains
how he slept with 2 200 women before the
age of 43 and shows evidence to prove it
X's are uh the number of people oh my
what oh my go disgusting that is your
man
[Music]
girl hey 90day fans famam it's melissia
happy holidays let's not waste any time
and get into Johan's lack of memory when
it comes to memory with an ey last week
Danielle accused Johan of speaking to
more than 50 women while they were
together attempting to scam them which
Johan denied Johan do you still maintain
that you w weren't speaking to these
women see but shout out to the producers
because one of them came up with the
brilliant idea of bringing one of those
women on the show catching Yan
completely off
guard please welcome
memory
uhoh sucks to be
Johan hi memory hi Johan is looking like
I I reached out to her yes apparently
you did disturbing this Nic looking
Wells spoken young lady tell me how did
Johan first approach
you um he slid in my Facebook messenger
and said hello at first it was like 11
o'clock at night and then he was asking
me you know was I married did I have
kids it just kind of went from there
memory says our conversations went from
hey how you doing to him telling her to
come visit the Dominican Republic my
friend and I had talked about doing like
a mom trip to the Dr so I just asked
about it and he was like you don't need
to bring a
friend you know I'll show you anything
that you need to see you can just come
here and see me I don't want to harshly
judge Johan because I didn't grow up in
the Dr I don't know his struggle but if
I'm to be honest and if what memory is
saying is totally
true if it's not looking great for him
there's something very disturbing about
someone who would do whatever it takes
to get what they want even if it means
manipulating innocent people in this
case women who desire love as if you and
what you want are more valuable than
them he had told me that he was single
going through a divorce and that she was
trying to take everything from him his
hats shirts and Hangers that she bought
yep she did try to take that I don't
know what else he's talking about maybe
Gizmo Y no give me the dog give me the
dog Sean asked Johan if he remembers
talking to memory
no
well memory makes it clear that she did
not reach out to Johan first no ma'am
and shows the
conversation he just said ol and I said
hello I told him I was going on a trip
and he said that's okay do you have kids
and a
husband and I said I'm single but I do
have a child and you he said I'm single
and I don't have children I'm getting a
divorce
I said oh no I'm so sorry I've never
been married but I can imagine it's hard
to get a divorce are you okay and he
said more or less can I see a picture of
you now and I just said I'm sorry and
then I told him that I saw on his
profile that he was from the Dominican
and he said I've been trying to get my
best friend to go with me and he said
you can come alone I can take good care
of you if you want I have no problem
with that where do you
live he said he could take good care of
her and I find it interesting that he
asked where where she lived I wonder if
he was trying to see if the location was
worth the
investment the internet can be a
dangerous place what would you do if
Johan slid into your DMs ladies it's
possible he's out here doing it to
randoms like memory who was just minding
her business on Facebook and all of this
happened while Johan and Danielle were
already cast members on 90day
fiance that's so bold
Johan do you remember this exchange
now I don't see how you can speak to
someone named memory and not remember
her Johan contacted me June 6th at 10:59
p.m. it's right there that's the very
first
message was this when you guys were
together he was messaging her or was
this already when you were separated uh
um this is before this is June so this
is before we moved out but we were
fighting I'm almost like I believe he
doesn't remember her and my question is
for him Danielle asked Johan if he
doesn't remember memory because there
are so many women who can sit in that
chair and say the same thing I believe
that he doesn't remember her I think he
has so
many memory goes on to share why she
stopped talking to Johan it's because
Danielle added her as a friend I
messaged her and was like hi you know
I'm assuming that you added me because
of Johan and she she said yes that that
was the reason and you know I had told
her everything that he had told me and
she told me you know he's still very
much married and I don't have anything
to do with married men that was just
that was the end of it I didn't talk to
him anymore now if you thought that was
something after they say bye to memory
Danielle alleges Johan carried out
inappropriate relationships with some of
her clients all of this allegedly went
down as Johan was supposed to be helping
Danielle out as one of her staff they
engaged in some kind of relationship
while she was on my retreat he used his
position in my business for his own
sexual
benefit the first time he went and
picked up another woman in my retreat
van and took her to maybe or maybe not
my apartment it just gets worse and
worse the second time he engaged in a
relationship with one of the women who
was there apparently during the retreat
he went to one of the women's tents at
night I
[Music]
mean yeah it's the lowest of the low at
this
point do I ever say anything without
proof I know that's right Danielle pull
out the rece seats Yan should consider
thinking before he speaks he sets
himself up with some of the things he
says I had found a picture on his
computer of a chat that they had I knew
something was up so I was like I need
you to do me a favor I need you to
delete my husband's number from your
phone this is making me very
uncomfortable I don't think you guys
should be having private conversations
and she said no problem done and then
just like two weeks ago she sent me an
email and was like hey I'm ready to talk
about this and detailed their
relationship the girl went on to tell
Danielle that along with coming to her
tent during the retreat he also tried to
convince her to leave the property to
quote spend time together and he wanted
her to stay back when it was time for
her to leave the retreat because
Danielle was headed to New York did he
really not think Danielle would
eventually find this out or did he not
care but if he didn't care he wouldn't
be denying it and he
is I don't I don't get it after you
talked to me and told me not to talk to
him anymore I told him that I couldn't
talk to him anymore and he got super mad
and told me that I was letting you
control me and I was afraid of you I
truly wasn't chasing your husband I
wasn't calling him on FaceTime he was
calling me and you entertained
it at least she came out and told her
that's interesting Danielle set up this
Retreat to help people heal do yoga
focus on their well-being meanwhile more
damage is being done to her heart I
wonder if the girl felt bad you have
this woman that's trying to provide a
service to help you and you're
entertaining her man are you convinced
that this woman and Johan had a physical
relationship yeah Johan continues to
deny deny
deny and then he gets extremely
disrespectful
[Music]
I am over him trying to send everybody
to hell when he's the one who needs to
quit lying he bold face lies he's done
it before I asked Johan about it I was
like did you go to the ATM and take
money out of my account he's like no I
was like are you sure today there was
someone went to the ATM and took money
out and he's like no so I'm like okay so
I have to go to the bank and ask them
for a video of who took money out of my
account and then finally he's like yeah
fine and just like bangs the table and
was super
angry just give it up we're grown here
your relationship is already over just
tell the truth that would be better for
your image if that's what you're trying
to protect then to continue to lie have
some Grace and
dignity okay
yo Brie says I swear Kenny and Armando
are the only wholesome couple on the
show they're like a breath of fresh air
amongst the madness agree Johan do you
admit to cheating with any woman while
you were with
Danielle is he trying to pull
[Music]
a she's out of your league he's angry
because I made this public yeah no one
knew about this none of my friends none
of his family I didn't tell anybody what
I was experiencing and now you sit here
andate me instead of I be just be honest
just for
[Music]
one oh my God in what
man the way he's defensive he's been
caught like red-handed Sean asked Johan
one more time did he cheat at any point
during this
relationship oh my God so Johan are all
of these women
[Music]
lying does anybody believe Yan
no Kanani Danielle says she kept the
evidence because she knows Johan and she
knew he was going to lie and I know that
everyone already thinks I'm evil and I'm
mean to you so I knew that the only way
to protect myself is to
come the cast goes want to take a vote
by a show of hands how many people think
that Johan has been
unfaithful from the evidence today
everyone here everyone
here shakina is the only one that did
didn't raise her hand out of everybody
which isn't surprising because she's not
that fond of Danielle I never really
cared for Danielle and she hasn't even
woken up yet to her own man's behavior
which we'll get to in a sec I think
youran used to for green card for money
and stuff and um I personally think y
sorry oh he is hey M Wayne I'm glad
someone said that out loud nice
emotional thing for Danielle to go
through like who wants someone to suffer
with a
psycho the unfortunate part is that
Danielle is probably going to be the one
who takes on the financial burden of
this divorce Danielle let me ask you one
final question are you going to file for
divorce yeah absolutely I would love
love to know what Danielle's major
takeaways from this relationship are
what has this experience taught her
because this is one of those Life
Changers here hard
lessons all right real quick Ken from
the dark side and Barbie who was caught
up in his spill don't question it just
roll with it tiny baby she's my Barbie
and I am her K the cast tries to figure
out starer claim that he slept with over
over 2500 women before the age of 43 how
does 2500 happen I was trying to do the
math I don't know how old you are it
doesn't I actually did the math so 30
years it figured about a new person
every four to 5 days did any of you do
the math I didn't care that much the
number just sounded too
ridiculous by our
calculations 2500 women means you had
sex with a different woman every three
and a half days since your 18th birthday
was that in fact the
reality I'm not proud of that yeah you
are right Kenny's a real one he knows
what's up he has to be proud of it he
gave that information about the 2500
women when no one asked for it if he
wasn't proud of it he should have kept
that information to himself and just
left it at a lot I've slept with a lot
of women women over the years she kind
of goes on to share some information
that has me looking at sarper like dude
what's really going on here you also
have that freaking bottle collection of
yours you love to keep your memories and
I hate
it what is the significance of the
bottle collection it's nothing it's just
a collection he has a memory with each
bottle with a female and he keeps all
the bottles what the
y'all look at this bottle collection
that's a lot of
women what is sarper trying to prove
here does he think a higher body count
makes him more of a man does he need to
be reminded about how much of a man he
is every day does he believe sex is the
only valuable thing about
him something's going on here you know I
would actually love to see sarper in his
most Natural State without the stiff
hair without the makeup just sarper who
is he outside of a sex symbol this
number of
women a lot of people said they didn't
believe it and also like how did you
document it was it like stars on a chart
well he's doing three and four in a
night it's didn't he say one time I mean
uh let me tell you something I'm a
counting freak I mean she kind of knows
it and I count everything he is he's a
numbers guy
girl Sara proceeds to tell shakina he's
been hiding something from her from 98
to 2012 I recorded all my bed body
counts to a notebook oh my
God you just said you're not proud of
your number but you're literally keeping
a book it was old baby I don't care
don't ever say you're not proud of it
again sarper volunt arily goes and gets
the evidence to prove his body count AKA
The Notebook that he seemingly had
prepared to show because it didn't take
him long to get it can you
see oh my
gosh look at sar's face he's flipping
the pages like he's ashamed of himself
yet nobody asked him for this wait what
are the ex's X's one X's are uh the
number of people oh my what oh my God
disgusting obviously not disgusting
enough that is disgusting that looks
like fantasy football or something
Kanani's reactions have been the best
this episode no it's nice to see her in
a seemingly lighter space after all
she's been through is your penis still
attached to your body me what do the
colors mean good question colors
indicates how pretty girl was how pretty
the girl was yeah he he literally was
not picky he would sleep with anyone
Sean asked shakina how she feels after
seeing the Note book to make all these
women an ex in a book it just I don't
know I just I don't like it and then
sarper tries to give her another
perspective she kind of think it as a
trophy for you I mean you change this
kind of men to this one no that's not
how I look at it is the proof of this
okay no it disgusts me yeah he's
tripping he has some work to do I want
to know what drove him to sleep with so
many people and was there any point
where he at least thought to himself let
me slow down that's a lot of opportunity
to catch something also I hate that
shakina doesn't even talk to her sister
now because of this
relationship my family is so negative
they could not be more unsupportive and
I actually don't even talk to anyone in
my family since the show I wonder if she
still speaks to her
daughter this relationship seems to be
separating her from people who love her
the most It's Like She's suffering from
Stockholm syndrome everyone can clearly
see this relationship is toxic and she's
being controlled but she doesn't see it
that way then again when you're used to
unhealthy
relationships you've been with a l of
us what might be toxic to
others could be acceptable to you you
grew up in a super like hardcore and I
grew up Mormon it's very similar and
like being nitpicked and controlled for
every single thing that you do and it
makes you make poor choices in men I can
say
that like it it comes off with some of
the people that yes you're being
attacked but like for me I do it because
I'm worried
I think you're you're bringing your own
thing into my relationship like your
issues are yours they're not Rel to I'm
if every single person in the room is
seeing the same and you're the only one
that doesn't it comes off the only one
in it okay fine girl it is your life she
kind of leaves a tell all without saying
a word to the
cast I just feel like everyone you know
hates me I don't care let them I'm
curious to see if we will ever see her
and sharper on 90day again I'm glad it's
over all right 90day fans famam that's a
wrap for the other way season five per
usual I enjoyed you and your commentary
we can always keep the conversation
going on my socials on IG I'm at Itor
malisia and I want to do something fun I
want to do a Q&A on my YouTube channel
which is @ Mia Shay s h AE you can ask
me whatever you want of course let's
keep it appropriate anything about
myself anything about 90day if you want
my take on something let me know I can
answer all of your burning questions
just drop the questions below in the
comment section and of course subscribe
to my YouTube channel so you can be
alerted once the Q&A video is out but in
the meantime enjoy the holidays and be
on the lookout for the new season season
of the single life which premieres
January 1st the cast looks pretty solid
with Tyree Chantel Miss Debbie kimon
Jamal and Veronica Tim you're a
dude who what you're not going to do is
Raise Your Voice me what you're not
going to do is question me being a dad
to Chloe you're way below the line yeah
I'm excited for it all right make sure
you stick with ET because we are
covering it all I will see you next
time